look at Neil Patel he has SEO services
but he makes his money doing it for
Fortune 500. garyvee a normal agency
business but he sells to Fortune 500
Salesforce over time they went up market
and so they went Enterprise so they went
to Fortune 500 companies going up Market
is harder but it pays off in the long
run if you envision a triangle this is
the whole Marketplace you can go up
Market every segment has a higher or
more leveraged version of its core
Market if I were to sell it at hair
salons I'd go up Market to
multi-location chains or big National
corpse or franchise the pros are the
deals are worth significantly more and
they churn far less often because you're
dealing with more sophisticated business
owners you don't have non-payment issues
the cons are they're harder to sell
sometimes it takes six 18 months to
close Enterprise deals bottom line if
you increase the quality of your
customer you increase the quality of
your company